hey guys look at the microphone hey guys
how's it going
ah hey guys how's it going we're
currently in the hotel room here at
VidCon I have a green screen set up here
I've got a camera here and we are
currently awaiting people to arrive at
our hotel I feel like I feel like
Michael Scott when he set up a party in
his hotel room and he was just waiting
for people to arrive like I got the
balloons I literally got the helium
this place is good these people arrived
but they haven't yet we're shooting a
mega collab a big ol boy with this green
screen over here and it's gonna be super
super super fun I can't wait to do it
but you guys don't know anything about
it yet because it can't be revealed
until we do all the work on it so many
people that are gonna be here Dan and
Phil are gonna be walking through the
door at some point here and then lesser
youtubers that no one cares about them
all right am i right Amy am i right oops
anyway hi guys I'm here with no I can't
mention any of that yeah I'm here with
Tom Scott Charley and Jack of Jack's
films here we're gonna be shooting a
collab on that green screen over there
with this camera and I really got
nothing else to say because I've spent
time actually chatting and getting this
stuff on your beautiful we're gonna kiss
off with this oh hell yeah yeah sure
recording yeah alright happening hi guys
I'm sorry it's very distracting
I'm here with more people in the room
yeah say hi
but either way we're filming a big
mystery collab that you guys don't know
about yet on that green screen yes this
camera yada yada yada
so hey logging so much let's get out of
here yeah you're good there you're good
you just touched the edge there I just
won't stick my arms up and Moga safe or
gels okay so we just finished filming
done with Dan and Phil here he broke the
lobby he did it was pretty much begs
myself thank you guys so much
did I miss a pun there was a strong more
do you analyze a pun the less it works
but either way thank you guys thank you
goodbye but now we got Brizzy and TJ and
I'm sorry James James James / James are
joining us here so we'll see that then
see it okay ready all right so we're
about halfway through all the people
that I asked to be a part of this
because everyone has been so on board
it's like they have no idea what's going
on they're like sure okay we'll go to
your hotel room being here I cannot wait
I can't wait it's gonna be so funny so
you guys will see more soon I forgot to
take pictures with everybody hi I'm here
with Dan hey yeah yep hi I'm here with
the gregory brothers also known as mo
Yoho - one member but they're all here
and we just I'm gonna keep going with
this we just did a collab and it was
cool right not highly cool yeah yeah
it's more than cool yet involves some
killers so I gotta say we've never done
a collab with killer
cool
first anyway it was an honor to have you
guys here likewise an honor to be here
thank you it sounds like we're gonna be
in a montage of so we're very excited
yeah is a privilege hello we are almost
done wrapping up for this session it's
so distracting strange it looks so weird
what's so distracting I'm sorry crazy
hey guys it's me markiplier with Pamela
Horton Hey
hi we just finished filming our big mega
collab for now we got more people that
are gonna be trickling in overtime but
the main bulk of it 9 people or more
than nine people 9 youtubes well
potentially 10 if we get you in on this
yeah and then a few more if they are
able to spare some time VidCon is very
busy for everybody I want to say thank
you everybody they're joining me for
this adventure Thank You Pam yeah okay
ID sorry videos are late today but okay